[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
car notre liste est un collectif citoyen
qui est le travail des jeux désormais
depuis un an maintenant et qui est une
équipe totalement soudés cohérente
renouvelé et dynamique et qui est à
l'image de notre ville et qui porte un
projet d'avenir pour la commune or point
phare il pourrait y en avoir plusieurs
mais notre action sera basée avant tout
sur la concertation tout au long de
notre mandat et sur les projets priorité
que nous avançons maintenant depuis
plusieurs mois maintenant
telle la transition écologique la
proximité la solidarité et la
convivialité de soutien à l'économie
locale et à l'emploi et bien entendu une
véritable démocratie participative est
renouvelée des axes qui répondront à
tous jeunes seniors et toutes les
familles
[Applaudissements]
la crise que nous venons de traverser a
quelque peu rebattu les cartes par
rapport aux 15 mars dernier bien entendu
nous aurions amener quelques priorités
différentes
mais là il me semble urgent et
nécessaire dans la période que nous
vivons est pour eux le les mois à venir
des nôtres dès notre installation le 29
juin prochain d'installer une commission
et économique et de l'emploi ouverte à
tous les professionnels les entreprises
chrétienne pour relancer de manière
coordonnée notre notre économie locale
de proximité mettre en place une
organisation locale du plan du plan
local par de santé et du handicap avec
les professionnels de santé de la
commune et bien entendu mettre une
veille d'une cellule de veille pardon
sanitaires sur la possible canicule qui
pourraient être des nôtres
malheureusement cet été
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]